did you like to do the honors certainly
would Reince Chastain
are you ready for this would you rather
play a Ouija board with friends or spend
the night in a cabin in the woods on
your own
a Ouija board with friends done it
before oh you have yeah did you feel
like there was like a spirit named
Michael was a little boy that was
talking to me in particular but I think
one of my friends was trying to scare me
or there's a little boy right behind you
right now talking I know take him
everybody's my assistant would you
rather see something terrifying behind
you thank you Michael in a mirror or
feel something touch your foot while
it's hanging out of your bed oh whoa I
think that behind me thing is it would
rather that yeah I would rather that
yeah because when you you don't want you
the place where you I don't think I'd
ever want to get back in bed my only
criticism in the first it movie was that
Sofia has that incredible bloody moment
in the in the bath and it's just
terrifying
and then like 20 minutes later she's in
the back to reading delay oh that she
got from bet you're like yeah I'd never
get back in that bath in my life let
alone have a nice relaxing bath looking
at my love Lera would you rather hide
from a villain under the bed or in a
closet in a closet because there's more
things you can pull from to fight with
yeah what do you keep under your bed
nothing nothing that's what yeah nothing
I keep boy heavy things under my bed oh
so then for you it would be fun there's
a few real heavy pointy sharp things on
top of this you're lying down though
you're not in a fighting position you
know no just grab your feet and pull you
out I've been old school Fotolia in a
corpse tension near my bed so I could
maybe reach it from under your bed and
smack Pennywise design cause as it came
by the bed let this rhythmically to the
tune or the beat but a music in my feet
Oh James MacAvoy would you rather
receive the phone call when you're at
home alone and only hear heavy breathing
or receive a text from an unknown number
saying I can see both of them saying
quite kinky rather the heavy breathing
cuz you could always engage I'd rather
the text because I've out gotten the
phone call with the heavy breathing
creepy would you rather follow a strange
noise down into the basement or often to
the Attic I'm the person in the audience
that's like why are you doing that why
are you going down into the basement
following a scary noise why are you
going up into the Attic
I think I would go with attic and here's
me thinking so you're going up into the
Attic right start and there's like stuff
and there's maybe something scary gonna
thrust at you from the basement you
trying to back up the stairs it's gonna
be a lot harder than you watching
yourself down the stairs backwards
whilst you're swinging your truncheon or
spraying you can carry with a light arm
right the Attic you just curl yourself
if you know if you make up into the
Attic what if you get tight just gone up
the stairs into the Attic mm-hmm so you
would choose basement no I would choose
the Attic would you rather face a killer
clone or a possessed doll because that
makes me feel like they're human if
they're Pennywise they would just
represent my own fear so I can't conquer
that but a possessed doll that's demonic
yeah what if the possessed doll was
possessed by the soul of a killer clone
in your double would you rather spend
the night in a supposedly haunted hotel
or in an abandoned Hospital I mean I
have technically spent the night in an
abandoned hospital many times if the
night shoots and those things quite a
few times in New York quite freaky I'd
see that I've got previous yeah a
haunted hotel I like that
would you rather try to defeat Pennywise
as a child or as an adult Isaac as an
adult as a child
really what do you think in this film
they were successful no they weren't but
the the had more power as children
Pennywise says this actually at some
point I think he says I hope you're
gonna beat me your fears or what for me
is like when you were a kid you used to
believe in magic you said that's fairly
new series we did but you used to you
also believe in the power of magic no no
you believe in an IRS so how are you
gonna beat me we disagree on this one
well disagree with Sir Stephen King yeah
no not that yeah oh it's really good on
you I'm surprisingly heavy bull
all right Mac attack me would you rather
be chased by a masked killer or haunted
by a paranormal entity it's not a good
look it makes me perforate for your
eyeball that's really painful huh
oh that me sir and I'd say rather be
you've got a smaller head you can get on
there just get a tiny head does Jessica
testing little brain ah master killer
definitely cuz you at least you're
dealing with a kind of a physical entity
that's real and not like hey ice last
you in the guy's like who I'm ghost
exactly and that was it okay
[Music]